this one was our most voted on question
in the in the pre-chat people should
have early racing to get their questions
and comes from Sebastian are you doing
the right thing if you need motivation
for what you're doing that's a great
question you know um ever I think the
answer is always yes I kind of think
it's almost like um and by the way ever
and I think you're the world's favorite
broadcaster that's that's the world's
favorite broadcasters I see it appeared
that either you we're headed people like
James Corden the stuff like that who's
an import um I just think what I need to
say here is it's almost like you need to
feed your inner self and I could think
of analogies are obviously around
nutrition for health exercise for
fitness and wellbeing but I do think you
need to as an entrepreneur and business
owner you need to create some people who
will give you positivity and people who
give you sort of challenge I'm really
good critical constructive input and it
allows you to refine your ideas and
loads of ideas and I've done this you
know we came up with an idea in the
1990s and when we actually launched it
on the market it look materially
different from what our original idea
was because we listen to people listen
to customers they gave us great input we
never could imagine how customers would
have wanted to consume our product and
that allowed us to improve it so I do
think it's important to get motivation
because I do think you need to feed
positivity optimism and also feed your
idea because otherwise I think you could
lose the will to pursue your dream so I
definitely I would I would be an
advocate of motivation positivity and I
do kind of see it as a almost like a
food you need to be consumed it as an
entrepreneur yeah i agree i think we all
have moments of doubt i don't think
there's anybody who never doubts
themselves and always
you know is is fearless one hundred
percent of the time you need that in
your life what I would what I would
examine Sebastian is if you are I don't
examine the motives like why do you want
to do this why is this business so
important to you whatever this thing is
that you're trying to do why does it
mean so much to you and if it comes down
to that you don't you don't love it
anymore we're going to just try to make
the money then then the motivation won't
help you you know then it's time to move
on and do something else you can get all
fired up by um but I think like for me
I'm it's a it's a daily thing I wake up
and I need to use my morning routine to
get me fired up for the day right put on
the music do the do the exercise in the
morning you know like that I have my
morning routine that gets me all set up
and I need to do that every day because
I kind of have a great talk with Stephen
Kelly guys I'm gonna like fired up for
the rest of the the afternoon I'm going
to wake up the next day and I like to
start from scratch again and so I need
that consistently in my schedule but I
think if you find that you don't love
what you're doing anymore then it's time
to move on to find something else Steven
what's here you have a crazy morning
routine you're up and like you're
running and yeah I love I trying to
tickle I I've done a lot of travel we
did these kickoffs around see all our
colleagues so we did like one week
damager and it's Berg from London to
Pretoria up to Paris the next day on the
Tuesday I think then we went down to
Madrid Wednesday up to a place in the
north of England Newcastle and then
friday we finished up in Frankfurt so
I'll be honest it is full on its intense
is like from five o'clock in the morning
too or probably midnight and if I don't
try and on most of these things if again
sometimes it's just not possible where
if I get up and do I even a 20-30 minute
run on that one it was great fun
actually because we inviting the video
loads of things through the Sage
Foundation which is the charitable our
message and we got we did challenge all
our colleagues to chase and beat the CEO
so they all came out you know down down
to Johannesburg we went on a run
together with a load of colleagues Paris
was all mine blend I've got
like some crazy time like five o'clock
and outside the hotel is under there
must be 30 40 colleagues and loads of
these guys amazing what sacrifice for
them getting up even a narrow they're
coming in from the suburbs but we ran
from this hotel probably about five cats
quite long way uphill up to that amazing
church called sacre coeur which on top
of the hill in in paris and you were
overlooking the whole of Paris is on the
Sun started rising and it's magical you
know about why do I do it um it give
alyssa me it gives me energy and there's
loads of physical evidence about
endorphins and all this sort of stuff so
it is good and i just think at sharon
and i think probably one of my sort of
self criticisms i don't know where
there's a CD or 8 i'm pretty sort of
extreme i love a routine you know I kind
of like a routine so the same routine
sort of helps me get into the zone of
coming in the office have an energy you
know tackling good days and bad days
really some days good some days a less
good but it gives me a good start of the
day so and I think you know if you start
the day well then it's a great start to
the weekend and literally it gets you
off to right place in and if you do you
know if you've had a weekend it's funny
when you have weekends because you kind
of replace about holidays vacations
let's talk about this just a completely
thing that came into my mind loads of
people on vacation will think you know
reassess and priorities do I really want
to do this I've been at this business
two years and i'm really going to break
through is all too hard I'm hit sitting
here drinking tequila slammers in some
exotic resort in Hawaii you know oh and
and little voices are find on vacation
really get into or you can kind of turn
it and say actually it's a great time to
reflect and some things I'm doing the
business work in terms of my idea but
some of them I could do differently and
some people come back from vacation
hugely energized but also being able to
reflect from the
outside in on what wasn't going well and
then come back straight in with the
energy to fix it so it is good time too
if you can do that and I know loads of
people do things like honestly
mindfulness meditation I think you know
I applaud those people because it just
gives you the space to think and reflect
on what's working well and what's not
and you know to reconnect with your
passion so I love that any ever do you
do any of those things to help you get
in the zone ah so for vacations I I hate
beach vacations I could do maybe like
half a day at the beach and then I'm out
then I'm then I'm I gotta go see the
city or I'm looking at the restaurant
thinking how could this business be
better or you know analyzing the people
selling the the floats and anyway it's
like I I i need the stimulation in terms
of a morning routine though I wake up
like i watch the videos on my channel i
made the channel selfishly for myself
the famous entrepreneurs that we profile
worse for myself because i wanted to be
around these great thinkers and have
some of their mindset kind of seep into
me and it was a selfish pursuit that i
shared with others and they're enjoying
it as well and i find that I need that
on a rig look at my wall like I walk
into this room every day right we got
people that I look up to and I learned
from on my wall here and that's all part
I think everybody needs to design an
environment and a schedule that gets
them fired up you know like you may not
know who this guy is or those people are
like it doesn't matter it means
something to me so it's not like copy
mine and put it up on your wall find the
people that inspire you I have these
people looking at me when I walk into
the office it gets me fired up to go and
do the thing that I want to do and kind
of think a little bit bigger and get out
of the comfort zone so now you're you're
traveling in your different city every
time we talk and you know but for those
of you who are not jets it around the
world you know you can do something in
your home office right just have
something up on the wall that means
something to you make it special for you
I think it's great what you do evan i
think i would encourage us all to do is
reconnect us with our dream and whether
it's pictures or imagery or prose you
know to connect us with why we started
our business and what our big idea could
do to change the world and if you come
and see that every day I think that
gives you power